[Music]
yes I think there are elements of the
game that you should teach in terms of
like teaching because what poker really
does is teach you how to deal with
probabilities and uncertainties and
that's so integral to life you know with
everything everything we try to do you
know should we take this route or that
route should I go here on vacation or
there it's all about dealing with with
uncertainties and probabilities of
things happening and and poker is a very
fun and easy way to teach someone how to
do that
it's a shame people often put you know
poker in the same ballpark as just
general gambling just because some
people choose to play it for money but
you don't have to play it for money it's
just about about winning you can win
anything you can win pride you can win
match six all money and there are so
many like core fundamentals of the game
that I wish I had known age age ten the
these idea that these some ways of
thinking about expectation expected
value and what probabilistic thinking in
general that would have sped up a lot of
things in my life had I been more aware
of it and also learning how to evaluate
evidence that's something there is not
taught in school very rarely taught in
school learning how to change our minds
update our beliefs look at when we get
new information being able to wait is
that information reliable or not and
playing poker has taught me how to do
those much more accurately so if there's
a way to teach children through a game
and children love to learn through games
poker could be that one of those methods
I think something like being
mathematically minded is I mean I yep
there's probably some aptitude involved
in it but I still think it's the vast
majority of it is down to determination
and practice you can take someone I mean
if you can just
understand the concept of numbers in the
first place which I think the vast
majority of humans can then you can
train someone to be more mathematically
capable it's like learning a language
you know you start off as long as you
have that initial passion and desire to
get better then it's those little
incremental jumps and it makes me so sad
when I meet people who are like oh I'm
no good at math and I'm good at math and
if you actually keep asking them why and
go back in their history it almost
always comes down to some bad experience
they had when they were probably seven
years old and the teacher asked them you
know what's 5 times 5 and they screwed
up and their friends laughed at them and
then they just you know these barriers
get built and they're like oh it's not
my thing and I think that's it's just a
huge tragedy because most humans can
learn to be at least competent at basic
mathematics especially the mathematics
in involved in poker it's isn't really
not that complicated there's a lot of
approximations you can do and I I found
that I used to actually not be very good
at mental arithmetic I was fine if I had
a pen and paper and algebra that was
like that but in the moments mental
arithmetic I could never do but I
started playing poker and sort of just
practicing these things and now I it's a
skill I'm proud of so it's it's it's
just a willingness to keep plugging away
at it
[Music]